-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award-nominated
actress you know from films
like "Little Women,"
"Black Widow," and "Midsommar."
She stars in "The Wonder,"
which is in select theaters now
and available on Netflix
November 16th.
Please welcome back to the show
Florence Pugh, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
So happy you're here.
-Wow!
-You've done the show before,
but this is the first time
in person.
And it's a nice,
lovely difference.
-Yeah, but I did it
with slippers on.
-You did it with slippers on.
-Yeah.
-That's very kind of you
to admit
that you were wearing slippers.
I could tell something
was a little off.
-Yeah.
-You've had a very busy year.
-I have.
-And we talked last time
about how your grandparents
are very proud of you,
very involved in your life.
And you brought --
you brought your grandmother
to a red carpet.
This is the first time
she's red-carpeted with you?
-This is the first time
she's red-carpeted.
-And it was Venice.
So that's a pretty...
-It was huge.
-...considerable red carpet.
-I've never been on a carpet
like that before.
Maybe BAFTAs or Oscars.
But Venice was so massive.
And Gran came on
and got addicted to it.
Like, fully got addicted.
-So would you say she --
Did she have any trepidation,
or did she immediately
find her way into it?
-Well it started because --
I mean, it's actually quite sad.
She wasn't going to renew her
passport because she was like,
"Well, I'm not going to travel
before I die."
And I was like,
"That is so bleak.
And of course you are.
You're an adventurer.
We've got to do this."
So I said, "Well, Gran, like,
what about coming
to the premiere in Venice?
If you don't have a passport,
you're not going
to be able to come."
And so she renewed it
after that, because she said,
"Yes, I should come to Venice,"
and I was like, "Okay."
She came to Venice.
And the plan wasn't to go
on the carpet.
The plan was for her to come --
my family --
my whole family came.
And as I finished the carpet,
I turned around, and my gran
was in front of all these
shouting photographers
just standing there.
And I said,
"Do you want to come with me?"
And she goes,
"Oh, alright, then."
[ Laughter ]
So we march over
to the photographers.
It's quite, like, aggressive
when you're out there.
There's so many people
shouting, screaming,
so many photographers
asking you to look here
and there and everywhere.
And I take her on,
and I'm, like, looking at all
these photographers like,
"Be nice. Be really nice."
And they do it.
And I suddenly hear all these
people screaming from behind.
And I thought they were being
really rude to Gran.
So I was about to turn around
and, like, tell some people off.
And when I turned around,
the whole wall of photographers
behind me were all like,
"No, we want pictures!"
So my gran
then starts pirouetting
and, like, curtseying,
and it was amazing.
-I was wanted to say --
this is not the photo of a woman
who doesn't have a passport.
This is a woman of the world.
-Yeah.
-And anyone with a scarf
like that has to have
an active passport.
-She's raving. She's raving.
-Now, this is a thing I found --
Here's another lovely one.
Look at that.
And I do feel like she's willing
to share the stage with you.
It's very lovely how
she's willing to share with you.
-I know, I know, and
I twirled her and everything.
-Oh, my gosh.
It's very dangerous
to twirl a grandparent, FYI.
-And she said -- She goes,
"And I was wearing
my uncomfortable heels."
I was like, "Well done, Gran."
-Lesson learned.
So, I found this, because, you
know, we were talking backstage.
My parents are on the show
every year for Thanksgiving.
I thought I'd do it once,
and now there's no way
to take it away from them.
They're here every year.
This has also happened
with Gran.
Gran has now done
back-to-back carpets with you.
Here she is
for your latest film.
And so --
-Exactly.
So I didn't -- When we finished
the premiere in Venice for
"Don't Worry Darling," I said,
"Granny, do you think
you might want to do it again?"
And she goes,
"I think I should."
I was like, "Okay."
But between both premieres,
she wasn't feeling very well.
And so I wasn't
going to push her.
And when we got to that
premiere, I did the carpet
and, you know,
all of the madness.
And I turned to my right,
and again, in amongst --
In amongst
all the photographers,
she's standing there like this.
And I turn to my publicist,
and my publicist goes...
[Whispering] "She wants
to get on the carpet."
So I go over, and Gran, again,
she's like, "I'm here!"
She loves it.
-I heard you call her Granzo.
Is "Granzo" common or is that
just unique to your family?
-Granzo, Granzilla.
-Okay. Got it.
-Granny...
-So you've got a lot of
different nicknames for her.
-And now are you concerned
about, the next carpet,
she will have her own publicist?
Is that something you're...
-The last premiere, we went
to Ireland and we opened --
We did our premiere
there in Dublin.
When I got -- I sat in my seat,
and a fan came up to me
and said, "Is your granny here?"
And I said,
"No, she's not here."
She was like, "Oh.
Well, I made her something.
I'm a designer,
and I made her a handbag."
So I take this present.
And I go, "For Gran?"
And she goes, "Yeah, for Gran."
So all night long it was going
through my whole team's hand.
Like, "Make sure
this gets home to Gran."
So she's got fan gifts
and everything.
-I love it. As she should.
The whole world
has come around to a place
they should have been for years,
which is Gran's the one.
-Exactly. Gran is the one.
-Now, you obviously
grew up in England.
Thanksgiving not a thing there.
-Yeah.
-You have come to adapt it?
Are you going to celebrate it
this year?
-Well, yeah, I am going to
celebrate it.
I've done, for the last three
years, Thanksgiving.
Yeah.
For the last two, I've cooked.
This year,
I'm going to semi-cook.
-Okay. What is semi cook?
What are you going to take on?
-I'm not going to say
I'm cooking,
but I'm going to be there
if anybody needs me with a pan.
-Oh, so that sounds like
not at all cooking.
-That's like -- No.
Oh, my God. That's like my dad
cooking in a kitchen.
"I'm not cooking, but I'm
definitely going to take over."
-It is a very -- The stakes are
high with a Thanksgiving dinner.
-Yeah.
-How do you feel --
How would you grade yourself
the last few years you did it?
-I put a bit of a twist on it.
I don't do all
the bits and bobs.
Why is there sweet potatoes
and marshmallows? That's weird.
-No, it's awful.
Yeah. A lot of it's awful.
-Why are there sweeties
in your food, guys?
[ Laughter ]
-There's some terrible mistakes
we made years ago,
and now we're living with them.
Out of the chains of tradition.
I think that's the thing.
-Okay.
-So it's very smart of you.
But you cooked the full turkey?
-Well, n-- Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
So it sounds like
maybe you just made dinner.
-No, I make a really good roast,
actually.
-Okay, there you go.
-I just don't do
all the bits and bobs.
-Alright.
-I actually last year --
Because it all failed.
Like, the family...had COVID,
so I had to start doing
two roast chickens,
which wasn't that bad,
but there was no turkey left.
-Alright. I'm not complaining.
I give you full credit.
I also want to talk about
this wonderful film.
So you're going to stick around.
Is that alright?
-But what about
your Thanksgiving?
We didn't even talk
about your Thanksgiving.
-It's all done and ready.
I already cooked it.
-Really?!
-It's ready to go.
-Is it in the freezer?
-No, it's not in the freezer.
I have it at very low heat
in the oven.
I have it at 5 --
You keep it at 5 degrees.
You cook it
a month ahead of time
then just keep it at 5 degrees.
-It's going to be,
like, dry, like,
astronaut food by the end.
-You have to ladle gravy
over it every 15 minutes.
We're going to take
a commercial break,
and I'm going to
run and ladle it,
and then I'll come back
and we'll talk.
We'll be right back with more
from Florence Pugh!